Should the United Kingdom remain in the European Union?
Some of Asia's biggest companies, politicians, and investors say yes.
So, what's under threat?
Over a thousand Japanese firms invest more than 9 billion dollars in the UK every year.
Japanese car companies account for about half of the vehicles made in the UK,...
...exporting to other parts of Europe with preferential tariffs.
Hong Kong tycoon Li Ka-shing is one of the UK's biggest investors,...
...owning everything from mobile phone network Three to the port of Felixstowe.
He's been increasing investment in the UK...
...but says he would cut back if it leaves the Union.
During a recent UK visit, Chinese billionaire...
...and owner of Sunseeker International, Wang Jianglin,...
...warned that Chinese companies would consider moving...
...their European companies elsewhere in the event of a Brexit.
Tata Group, which owns Jaguar Land Rover...
...and other businesses in the UK, employs almost 70,000 people.
Senior executives say that if the UK leaves the EU,...
...it would become more difficult to buy components...
...and sell its products in its largest market.
It's not all bad news. One Indian conglomerate says if the British pound depreciates...
....in the event of a Leave vote,...
...it could bolster its aluminum and packaging businesses...
...because they bill UK clients in euros.